so my job is gonna be to introduce our
speaker you know when I first met him
you know I had just started working here
and yeah I remember very clearly that we
were talking and he was talking about
his background wondering if you know
Ryan was gonna be a good fit for the
things that I'm interested in and I you
know I was thinking as we talked I
thought gosh this guy is gonna be a
perfect fit for the things that you know
the things that we worked on and you
know he's been here he's done some
really really nice work and you know
that we'll talk about that you guys will
hear a lot more about so briefly you
know Ryan grew up in the Midwest and was
a University of wisconsin-madison
graduate you know where he studied
biology you know after that he spent a
few years doing basically production you
know type engineering quality systems
you know with manufacturing and then
then ended up here in the West Coast
where he got interested in biomedical
informatics so he's been in the
informatics program here now and you
know I would say that you know Ryan has
been you know great to work with we've
got a team of people you know kamal-ji
Sheree and Shannon's been working with
him a lot recently and yeah I know Mike
Mooney has helped you know with a lot of
stuff that Ryan does and yeah I would
say that one thing about Ryan is that
he's really really helpful in sports
sometimes they talk about people who
make the rest of your team better and
Ryan is exactly like that he's helped
out a lot of people you know with the
rest of the group on projects and so
he's going to talk about what he's doing
now so if you can help me welcome Ryan I
would say thanks to Mike for that great
introduction
so I'm Ryan Swan I'm going to be talking
about my dissertation work today a
little bit and I want to thank all of
you for for being here and attending so
what we're gonna be focusing on today is
I'm ready talking a little bit about
this idea of making network based
polygenic risk score and looking at
specifically how we can apply that in
retinopathy prematurity and preterm
birth so to talk a little bit about what
we're talking about when we talk about
these two phenotypes preterm birth is
generally described as children who are
born before 37 weeks gestation with
extreme preterm birth considered
children
born for 28 weeks gestation it used to
be that pneumonia was the largest killer
of infants
but over time preterm birth has now
overtaken it along with the core
morbidities associated with it
so when we look at things that are
investigated as causes of preterm birth
we see a lot of things that are across
the spectrum so we see different
environmental factors and exposures we
see things about the morphology of
mother's bodies or things like cervical
length or other physical features there
are features of placental development
that are important for preterm birth as
well as the immune system and hormonal
responses and then in addition to this
we also have systems that are present in
the infant in addition to those that are
present in the mother and you get this
kind of dual response that's happening
and genetics has been theorized to
contribute in all of these cases but the
genetic heritability of preterm birth
estimated some place at about 40 percent
of the outcome meaning that about 40
percent of the outcome of the disorder
is reliant on genetic causes when we
talk about retinopathy prematurity which
is the other thing that we're interested
in especially the work that Mike does
we're talking about a disorder that
occurs in premature infants specifically
and generally what we see is this
formation of the vascular Ridge as you
can see on this left figure here in the
eye and then there's a an increase in
vascular development that causes a
tractional detachment of the retina from
the eye leading to blindness and back in
the 40s in the 50s ROP was the largest
cause of blindness lifelong in in
infants and now it accounts for
someplace between 6 and 18 percent of
cases of blindness in the past a lot of
studies of RP were focused specifically
on oxygen exposure but as time has gone
on we've got better at controlling
oxygen exposure in infants and we've
seen some of those cases get a little
bit less but as we've gotten better at
saving preterm infants and increasing
their viability we've seen cases of RP
overall continue to grow so this is
something that we're very interested in
in studying the presentation of ROP we
consider this a complex phenotype that
has multiple axes of development so you
have this idea of zone which is how
close that Ridge happens to the center
of the eye
obviously the closer it happens to
center the item more serious it's gonna
be because that's where your vision
comes from we have this idea of stage
which is the degree of retinal
detachment that happens over the course
the disease so at the higher stages of
disease you see total retinal detachment
and total blindness we also have a
couple of other ways of considering ROP
which involved these phenotypes of + ROP
and a PR LP where + ROP represents a
version of ROP that happens with more
venous tortuosity these twisty looking
veins like you see on the right and then
an aggressive posterior ROP which is a
faster progressing form of RP where you
see even more of that tortuosity and
then more dilation of the blood vessels
and leaky blood vessels so that's
considered a much more serious form of
disease when we consider the causes of
ROP there are a number of genetic
factors that have been looked into in
addition to just considering
environmental factors like oxygen the
most exhaustively studied of these is a
factor called veg F which is vascular
endothelial growth factor but genetic
studies individual haven't really
provided a smoking gun showing us that
there's one particular mutation or a
group of mutations that's responsible
for most of the outcome of the disease
and so researchers have looked at a
number of different things they look at
things that are involved in inflammatory
effects they've looked at similar
diseases like nori disease which has a
similar expression of a similar
phenotype to ROP and a similar
progression they've looked at nervous
development so things like brain derived
neurotrophic factor which is involved in
development of nervous tissue like the
retina and then a whole host of other
things including other angiogenic
factors and when we look at the
heritability of ROP it's actually got an
estimated genetic heritability that's
relatively high someplace around 70% so
we have reason to believe that there
should be some sort of a genetic
contribution to this disease based on
existing studies so we have this issue
of two different disorders one of which
is preterm birth and the other which is
ROP and the fact that they both happen
at the same time and ROP tends to occur
in extreme preterm birth cases but it
also occurs in other cases at the same
time so it seems like these two things
may have separate causes
we want to be able to come up with a way
of telling the difference between them
because at some level it seems like
we're looking at the same thing twice in
some ways we're trying to figure out
which one of these things is causing it
is one just a feature of the other or
are these two totally separate events so
this brings me to the idea of looking at
polygenic risk scores so polygenic risk
scores are essentially a method of you
want to be able to look at a population
of people and then look at the DNA of
those individuals and based on what you
see in the DNA come up with some sort of
a score that schedules these people
between being very low risk and very
high risk or someplace in between this
figure is from a study into obesity so
you can see that you start with a bunch
of individuals where you have no prior
information on them and then we look at
their DNA and based on things that we
see there we can give them a continuous
score between being very high risk or
very low risk for something like obesity
so what is this actual score when I talk
about a score the general idea is that
we have some sort of a training set
where we have a cohort of individuals
that have some representation for the
feature that we're interested in when we
perform a genome-wide Association study
in that group and then from that we get
a number of significance values and
effect sizes so things describing both
the level of Association that these
things have and then the degree of
effect they have on the outcome linked
to individual positions across the
genome known as snips or single
nucleotide polymorphisms so once we have
that list of snips and significances we
can cut out the least significant snips
so we're only dealing with the ones that
have the most signal then we can go
through and for each individual we can
see which of these they have and then
sum up the effect sizes for the snips
that are present so for example here you
might see the person on the left as
having the lowest risk of achieving
whatever outcome you're interested and
the person on the right might have the
highest risk normally when we're doing
this in individuals you have either one
or two copies of each of these because
of course you have two copies of your
your DNA but here just for simplicity
I'm just adding it up as if everybody
only has one so what we can do then is
we can repeat this through a wide
variety of individuals in a test set and
from that test set we can arrive at some
sort of a measure of fit that gives us
an idea of how well our score performs
at predicting outcomes so these are
going to be the general things I'm
talking about when I talk about poly
Chris course today so polygenic risk is
something that has been used recently a
lot as we've gotten larger cohorts of
individuals that have phenotyping in
order to look into a wide variety of
different disorders we look at things
like cardiovascular risk height its
perennial obesity and then even more
anomalous things like intelligence and
educational attainment or addiction have
been looked at using these scores so
despite their wide variety of
applicability there are some issues with
PRS that make it more difficult to apply
them widely to a number of different
things
so the first off is that in general
these require a larger sample sizes
often PolyJet risk scores have performed
best when we're looking at groups of
hundreds of thousands of individuals and
there's some theorization that maybe you
need millions of individuals to get the
best possible polygenic risk scores and
because of this were limited to looking
at common traits so if there's a really
rare disorder it's difficult to form
some sort of a polygenic risk or to
predict their outcome because you can't
get a big enough recruitment of
individuals to get that level of
predictive ability and then another
issue with these is that we have
problems when we consider the biological
context that these scores represent
because really what we'd like to know is
not just what is contributing to or what
what a person's likelihood of achieving
a disorder is but maybe what systems are
contributing to that or if there are
parts of the biological system that are
having an outsized effect on their
outcome so we also see that there are
problems with population differences so
if you build a score for example in a
Caucasian population and then try to
apply it in an african-american
population or a population of Asian
descent they don't translate as well as
we would like them to and this is a
current challenge that we're trying to
overcome and finally the kind of the
aggregate of all of these challenges is
that we haven't been able to translate
these into clinical utility yet
generally the amount of signal that we
get back from a polygenic risk score
isn't high enough for us to want to use
it in the clinic to schedule people's
treatments or to change the way that
they're going to be treated medically
so all this brings me to the idea of
bringing network context into
construction of these apologetic risk
scores
so what we're interested in in our first
name is just looking at a set of height
phenotypes to be able to try and
describe a method that we can develop of
trying to bring this information in and
then describe how that changes the
formulation of the scores and the
information that we get back from them
both for predictive ability and for
capturing biological context so if we're
talking about preterm births and ROP why
are we interested in height here so
height is a very well described
phenotype that's very easy to measure
there are a lot of data sets that have
very high recruitment with a lot of
individuals that have height data and so
this is a very good way to build our
scores and be able to compare them to
other studies that have been done in
polygenic risk because it's kind of a
canonical feature that these have been
done in so in order to build our score
what we're looking at are a couple of
data sets one from a consortium called
giant consortium that's looking at
anthropometric data and a very large
group of meta geoff's this is combining
I think 75 or 79 G losses together into
one giant cohort of about 250,000
individuals and that forms our training
set that we're going to build our score
in and then we have this Michigan health
and retirement study which is around
10,000 individuals that are phenotyped
for height as well this is a
longitudinal study of people in the
latter half of their lives looking at
disease outcomes but we're really
interested in the phenotyping
specifically and then in order to build
our network we're looking at a couple of
resources one of which is the in sambal
database of gene positions which gives
us the location of a number of different
genes throughout the genomes that we can
map our snips to them and then the
string database of protein-protein
interaction which is a database of
different proteins and how they talk to
each other based on curated and
predicted data so the process of mapping
our snips to genes and I apologize this
is a little bit small
but basically what we do is we have a
bunch of snips that are located you
could think of this as a chromosome or a
stretch of DNA and then using the
assemble gene regions we can line up
which gene regions fit with which snips
and then we can filter the genes that we
want to include based on some criteria
here we're thinking about using Network
criteria in order to pull certain genes
out so imagine here that gene 3 doesn't
meet our our threshold so we pull that
out at the set
and then we expand our gene regions a
little bit by about eighty kilobases in
order to capture upstream and downstream
effects that could be promoters or other
things that cause the these genes to act
differently once they've been translated
into proteins so finally what we end up
with is we go through we find the things
that are assigned to these regions and
that set of snips comes through and ends
up being part of our score and the ones
that are in between those groups do not
make it through and those are discarded
so our general workflow has two branches
one of which is this idea of early
network context integration where we
look at the network first before we even
looked at the genetic data and the other
is this idea of late network context
integration where we're looking first at
building the score and then using a
network to pull apart that score after
it's been constructed the early network
context methods what I'm gonna go into
first here a little bit so the general
workflow that we're doing is we start
out with a string database we translate
that into a data object that we can
manipulate in Python in the package I
graph and then using that Network we can
go through and we can look at different
attributes here the example is
connectivity and we can identify nodes
that are interesting to us we can then
prune back the network to just the nodes
that we're interested in and then find
snips that map to those nodes and use
those in order to create our polygenic
risk score
so when we think about ways that we can
use to construct a polygenic risk or
there's a number of different
assumptions that play into this and
there's a lot of different ways that we
want to consider and be deliberate about
which assumptions we are addressing with
each one of these models so I'm going to
describe four different ways that we
constructed polygenic risk scores using
network context and then show you a
comparison of how they performed the
first of these models is just the
standard PRS so this is our control
we're taking basically everything that
we're given and then adding it into the
model what we do there is we basically
take all the snips regardless of whether
they map to a gene region or not we then
go through and we do clumping for
linkage disequilibrium which is
basically finding regions of DNA that
travel together and we pull out a snip
that's representative of that clumps
that we're not getting a lot of signal
from one set and then we find the best
fit threshold using software called
precise which goes through and finds
where we have the best significance
threshold for predicting these snips
or predicting these outcomes and then we
take that model as our threshold and
remove the snips that don't meet it so
this general workflow is what we're
going to use for all of our scores but
just the the first step of curation is
what's really going to change between
them so the first score that's a tweak
on this is the assumption that we want
to say that genes are probably more
biological than not or biologically
significant than non genes just the idea
that things are being translated into
proteins probably have more of a role on
biological development and expression of
these different phenotypes and things
that might just be considered intragenic
snips that are falling in between and so
what we do here is we first find snips
that map to gene regions that we've
described based on our mapping procedure
and then anything that falls between
those is thrown away and we carry
forward to the same thing we set a
threshold we take the significant snips
and we make the score from that the next
model is taking this a step further so
the assumption that not just that genes
are important but that perhaps the genes
that talk to a lot of other genes are
important so here we're interested in
this idea of degree connectivity so
we're looking at how many neighbors each
one of these nodes has so one gene my
talk to one other gene one gene my talk
to 50 or 100 other genes and we're
saying that we think that maybe that
hundred gene partner set is probably
more important so we're going to look at
the top 50 percent of the nodes by
degree connectivity and we're going to
pull those out and putting the network
back and take the snips that fall into
those regions and then construct our
score from those now the final idea is
this idea of a candidate gene polygenic
risk course there are a number of poly
or a number of candidate gene lists that
are out there that are curated by
clinicians and our assumption here is
that this clinician expertise should
translate into better predictive ability
and in general what we do is we go
through and we find the genes that are
described by these these candidate gene
scores or kind of gene lists excuse me
we select them on the graph and we
expanded the neighbors of those genes
and we take anything falling into these
sets forward into the score that we
build so we have one issue when we look
at height specifically which is that
height doesn't really have a well
curated
candidate gene list that fits our
purposes and so what we wanted to do was
to take some sort of a simulated
candidate gene list for height so we did
as we looked in another study that was
similar to the the study of we're
building our score in that also came
from the giant consortium and we look at
the top 500 snips by significant in that
group and we found genes that were
associated with those snips so the genes
that those snips fell into we selected
those genes on our graph and their
partners and we carried that through to
build our score so when I'm talking
about the high candidate gene score just
keep in mind that we're using a
simulated one in this particular case so
when we're comparing these models we
want to pay attention to how they
perform differently and whether they
perform better or worse and then by how
much they perform better or worse in
order to do that we're going to be
looking at this this measure of fit so
the fit to the the test set that we've
been able to calculate so we look at
these four scores they're laid out here
from left to right and you can see that
the all snips score does indeed
outperform our network modified scores
which is interesting to look at because
it seems that coverage is an important
thing here so there's there's been a lot
of discussion around how best to build
these scores and in general polygenic
risk scores just take everything forward
and it seems that we're seeing that
effect here that said on the right here
you can see the number of snips that are
included in each one of these scores and
we have a pretty big drop-off in the
number of snips that are included so we
lose roughly 50% of the snips in the set
when we go to just the all gene score
but we see a relatively small step down
in the amount of predictive ability that
we're seeing and then again we see a
step down in the number of snips that's
available in the connectivity score but
we're not seeing a huge difference in
the amount of prediction compared to the
all gene score and then as we get to the
candidate gene score we're losing about
95% of the snips that are involved but
it's still clawing back a score that's
about 37% lower than the all snips score
so this is interesting to us because we
want to look at those candidate genes
and see if they actually have more
information than we'd expect to see from
a random set of snips so the first thing
that we can do to get some idea of this
is to look at the all snips score and
then just subtract out all the snips
that are involved in the
candidate genes score and we do see that
there is a decrease of about 18 percent
in predictive ability but we're not
seeing a difference in 11% or 11.11
which is the r-squared that we get from
the Canada gene score so it seems like
it's not coming all the way down with
the amount that the Canada jeans cork
contains but we are getting more than
we're pulling out 5% of snips and we're
getting 18% reduction so it does seem
that these snips are important that
makes sense considering that these were
simulated and pulled out of highly
significant snips from a similar study
so in order to take a little bit deeper
into this we wanted to look specifically
at a random background comparison to
these these scores so what we did here
was we basically grabbed a random group
of snips at different proportions of the
total snips that were available and
imper muted that 1,000 times and built a
thousand random polygenic risk scores
from them and the mean predictive value
of those scores across different
proportions of sniffs is shown here with
this dotted line and then the guides
along the outside of that represent two
standard deviations away from that mean
so interestingly what we can see here is
that while the all gene score seems to
perform in the range of that two
standard deviations the connectivity
score and the candidate gene score seem
to fall outside of it and perform
significantly worse than a random set of
snips from across the genome so this is
very important to take into account
because it really does seem that taking
a random set of snips is useful here
because you're getting again that large
amount of coverage across the genomes so
even if you're not getting the most
focused group of snips it seems that
you're getting better performance than
some of these network based methods so
based on this we can say that we have
some challenges for polygenic risk
scores built with networks when we're
looking specifically at improving our
predictive ability but there's other
contexts that we can learn from these
and there's other ways that we can use
them so we go back to this idea of an
early context approach and a late
network context approach and here we're
going to focus a little bit on this idea
of building our scores first and then
trying to pick them apart with these
networks in order to get an idea of
what's happening there biologically so
what we do in this case is we start off
with our gos data and we build our
polygenic
score from that we take that polygenic
risk or data and we load it onto a
network and then we use module detection
and we look inside of the modules that
we find using enrichment analysis and
here we're using GSE a methods in order
to find out if there are biological
annotations that are enriched in those
clusters I'm going to talk about two
ways of doing this
the first way that we did this was to
take those gos data and then load it
onto the graph and then go back and
prune it back
based on what met threshold of being
included in a score so only the snips
that would have been continuing through
to being an actual predictive snip when
we score people are included in this
graph and then we do module detection
using the levain algorithm which is a
modularity optimization algorithm and we
take those clusters and we look inside
them using gsa in order to see if
they're enriched in this case for gene
ontology information so we built a shiny
app in order to do this this analysis
that basically allows us to easily
manipulate a bunch of the data we can go
through and choose different clusters
and look at them we can see different
things from M sigdi be so different gene
sets or curated groups of genes that are
that are enriched inside of each one of
these clusters and we can also look
specifically at gene sets for ROP and
for preterm birth inside of them which
isn't going to plan when we talk about
the giant data right now but will be
relevant later so to give you a kind of
a perspective of how this looks inside
of each one of these clusters we went
through and we summed up the potential
effect size contribution that they had
to the to the outcome of interest here
being height and basically went through
and took the absolute value of all the
effect sizes inside of that cluster and
added them together and then looked to
see if they were enriched compared to a
random subset of genes from the network
so here again you have a dotted line
representing a bunch of random
permutations means and then a line
outside of that representing two
standard deviations away from it and
here you can see that there are a couple
of clusters that seem to be enriched for
effect size in the case of clusters 15
and 16 or under enriched in the case of
number 14 here then we also have a wide
range of the amount of effect size
that's captured
inside of these different clusters so we
have this one over here cluster two that
has the largest amount of effect that's
captured inside of it so what I'm going
to do just for brevity's sake is to look
at fifteen and number two and give you a
breakdown of what we see when we look at
the gene ontology enrichment for four
terms inside of there so cluster 15
which is the most highly enriched for
effect size we see a number of different
processes that are represented here a
lot of cellular transport things a lot
of localization and protein transport
and then we also see an interesting
group here in the middle where you see
skeletal system developments and animal
organ Morfitt morphogenesis coming up I
apologize if this is a little bit small
so that's something that's an
interesting outcome for us because when
we're looking at height you're
interested in a lot of these growth
phenotypes you want to be looking for
things that are systems that are
involved in growth and so at some level
it seems like we can pin that down to
this part of the graph and say that it
is contributing more of that predictive
ability here when we look at cluster two
which was the cluster that had the most
signal associated with it of all these
clusters we see a more diffuse group of
features so we see things that are
related to chromatin silencing and other
chromatin related processes and then
interestingly we also see this group of
processes that are related to head
developments and for brain development
and nervous system development so again
we're seeing things that we can kind of
extrapolate being related to growth or
being related to processes that would
have an outcome of higher or lower
height the second way that we pulled
apart these the biological context of
these graphs is that we use something
called hotnet 2 which is a preexisting
network analysis method that does
something called insulated heat
diffusion so what we started out with
here was we took the snip data we found
the lowest p value within each one of
the genes and translated that to the
negative log of that value making it
something that is a positive value and
then use that as a surrogate for heat
and then hotnet takes that heat and just
sort of spreads it out across the
network as if you have a bunch of little
fires and then you can look at which
sub-modules hotnet detects that are
enriched for that signal versus a random
subgraph so when we look at the sub
graphs that hotnet to returns for us
these are the top three performers and
interestingly we do see that these are
strongly enriched for things like growth
factors we see a number of skeletal and
tissue development factors and we see a
number of things that are related to
height related diseases or morphology
related diseases things like Marfan's
disease and this is a really powerful
demonstration that there do seem to be
sub networks across the graph that are
relatively small that are contributing
some predictive ability to the way that
we're able to predict these scores so
now that we've looked a little bit at
how we can build some of these scores
using network context and we can pull
apart some of the biological information
that's available we want to get back to
ROP in preterm birth and this idea of
trying to separate these two very
similar similar presentations of disease
from one another and see how intertwined
they are and if there's a way that we
can use these polygenic risk scores
involving network context to do so so
when we're looking at preterm birth and
ROP the data set that we're considering
is this group from the Danish national
birth cohort which you'll notice is much
smaller than the group that we were
looking at for giant but it's large one
of the largest curated data sets in
preterm birth that we can get our hands
on
so this consists of 1,000 mother infant
pairs and 1,000 or 1,000 feet our mother
infant pairs and 1,000 full-term mother
infant pairs and here we're considering
just the infants from that group and in
addition to that we have a preterm birth
candidate gene list which was put
together by the folks at Brown
University which is called database of
preterm birth or DPP TB and then as part
of the study we also created our own
curated gene list for ROP using
literature review which ended up being a
group of about 125 genes that has
previously been investigated or or
looked at in RP and what we're
interested in doing here since we don't
have a good data set for for the
genetics of our RP we don't have one
that has enough ROP candidates in it to
look at specifically is we want to see
how well we build an ROP candidate gene
score based on our candidate gene list
does this predict disease in the preterm
birth group so we're looking to see if
our ROP score predicts preterm birth
with the thought that if it is good at
doing so then that's some evidence that
maybe these two disorders are strongly
overlapping so the way that we
constructed our score was we took 75
percent of the data from D NBC as
training data we built a Jewess from
that set and then we withheld 25 percent
as our test set which we did our
validation for fit and seeing how well
this performs at predicting so taking
that forward here we have the same four
scores that we built for the preacher
for the giant data but here you'll
notice that we have two difference R
Squared's one is for the novel cookie R
squared which is what we were using for
the giant data and one is the lis R
squared which takes into account the
prevalence the disease so this is just
two different ways of doing this score
but in general we can see that there's a
slightly different trend here where the
all snip score seems to actually be the
worst performer of the group again we're
looking at a very small amount to fit
compared to the height values which was
someplace around 0.18 here we're closer
to point the one which is much much
lower but you're seeing that the old
gene score here is performing a little
bit better at the connectivity score is
performing relatively the same as the
all snip score and then the candidate
gene score is performing someplace in
between what gets really interesting is
when we consider that score for ROP that
we did because it turns out that the ROP
score actually does a much better job of
predicting preterm birth outcome than
any of the other scores that we built on
this data and this is also despite the
fact that the ROP score has a very small
amount of snips that's involved in it so
here it's the smallest number of snips
and therefore the smallest amount of
coverage but also doing the best job at
predicting preterm birth despite being
built from a set of gene specific to our
ope so in order to dig into this a
little bit more again we wanted to look
at random backgrounds again it seems
that we're seeing most of these scores
falling inside of that two standard
deviations from the mean this is
interesting to look at because you see
that you do actually see a decrease in
predictive values include more and more
snips than this random score and our our
P score is still within those two
standard deviations but is doing much
better than what we would have seen from
how many of the other scores that we've
considered thus far
so it seems not to be significantly
different but we want to dig into that a
little bit more just to get an idea of
if there is anything inside of that
that's an interest to us so we do then
is we want to look specifically at the
overlap between the candidate gene score
for preterm birth and for ROP because we
want to have some sort of an estimate of
how similar these two scores are to one
another so that we can get an idea of
where potentially this huge difference
in predictive ability is coming from and
again interestingly we see that these
two scores are pretty similar to one
another there's actually 91% overlap of
the the group of snips that's in the ROP
score here or as sorry the the genes and
therefore the snips that are in the Art
Peace Corps and there's about 232 genes
that aren't included in that set so we
want to drill down a little bit more
into that group of 232 genes and see if
there's something in there that's highly
predictive of preterm birth so when we
look inside of that group of 232 genes
what we did here is basically did the
same cluster analysis that we did
earlier of trying to go through and see
that group of 2 or 3 2 genes as its own
cluster and then look at the raw number
ROM out of effect size that's available
inside that cluster and apportion it to
different genes and see what percentage
of that outcome was from each one of the
genes so our largest performer by this
metric is this gene USP 6nl which has
been implicated and infant development o
site development so that makes sense to
us and then these are just the next four
genes in order from that group based on
that criteria so we're seeing genes that
are involved in sun'll development or
seeing things that are involved in
general urinary tract development and
things that are involved in ovarian
cancer so in general this makes a lot of
sense that these would be highly
predictive genes that are associated
with preterm birth so the fact that
these are occurring in that cover of the
ROP genes that we've expanded to their
neighbors seems to give us some idea
that these two disorders are probably
strongly independent at least based on
where clinicians have been looking for
signal thus far again what we can do is
we can look at the score and what
happens when we subtract out the snips
that are in the ROP score so here we
start with the all snips score and then
we pull out all the snips that are
involved in the RP score to see what
happens to
ability and you would assume that this
would go down since these are highly
predictive snips but it turns out that
we actually get about an 11 percent
boost in our ability to predict based on
taking these snips out of the score and
this is interesting because it seems to
point to something else that might be
going on under the hood here there might
be something to do with the correlation
structure or how these snips that are
associated with ROP directionally
interact with this group or we might be
seeing some evidence of the fit with the
test set here so this is is an
interesting result to try and consider
and see why we don't see a larger
decrease in our ability so now I'm going
to turn a little bit to considering
what's going on inside of this group of
preterm birth snips again to see if we
can describe some degree of where the
biological information is coming from in
these systems and again when we compare
this to random background we end up with
a couple of clusters that are enriched
for for signal for effect size and
you'll notice again that this is a
little bit less extreme in their
enrichment and then we have one cluster
that's got much more signal than the
rest in this cluster 13 so again we're
going to look at the most strongly
enriched cluster for effect size which
is cluster 11 and we're going to go and
look at cluster 13 and see if we can
find anything inside of these that's
coming up for ontology z' that are
represented at a higher amount than we
would expect so when we look inside of
this cluster 11 which is the most highly
enriched one we're not seeing things
that are quite as definitive is when we
look at the giant data but we are seeing
things that are related to muscles or
seeing things that are related to
synaptic development so there's there's
some reason to believe that these are
providing an outsized effect at least in
our predictive ability and this
relatively small predictive ability that
we're able to have on this small cohort
in addition when you look at cluster 13
so this is the cluster that has the most
signal associated with it we have things
that are coming up involving things like
regulation of adhesion we see things
again related to neuronal development
and we see things that are related to
ion transport and these are broader
systems again and kind of
seems like a trend is that in these
larger clusters with a lot of things
inside of them you get back broader
systems that might be interacting so we
try to apply hotnet to to this data set
we actually see a failure for it to
converge which is unfortunate because it
was very useful in the giant data and in
this case the smallest cluster that it's
able to detect is of the size about a
hundred and eleven nodes and this is
probably just due to the high amount of
noise that's in a smaller sample so what
we would really like to see would be a
larger sample of data for ROP and
preterm births so that we can apply hot
net to to it and see if we can get back
some of these smaller networks that
might be giving outsized effect so from
there we can move into some of the
conclusions for what we've learned from
looking at this data the first thing
which is that when we construct these
polygenic risk scores using network data
we don't really see a big uptick in our
ability to do prediction we're seeing
generally a drop-off in our ability to
predict and this is actually in keeping
with some recent research that's been
coming out involving an omni genic model
of disease where in a lot of different
things are talking to each other and you
end up having a lot of effects that are
very difficult to pin down we're also
seeing that there is some evidence that
we're able to isolate modules that have
a function that's biologically
interesting that gives us some sort of
signal that we can use to focus the way
that we're contextualizing the results
of the predictions from these polygenic
risk scores and we're seeing that we can
describe some of that using networks and
pre-existing methods like hotnet - that
are out there we also see that we can
use these networks in order to assess
the overlap between different disorders
and how they are evaluated to try and
get an estimate of how difficult it
should be to pry those two things apart
and specifically looking at ROP and
preterm birth here it seems to give us
this picture that these two disorders
might be highly interlinked with one
another and finally we can say that
definitely these network based
investigations seem like they benefit a
lot from having a large sample size so
one of our hopes was that by applying
network based methods to these samples
we'd be able to
noise some of the the data and get a
better idea of kind of where the signal
was on a smaller data set so that we
could apply some of these to rare
disorders but it does appear that
they're still very sensitive to sample
size and that they benefit a lot from
having a lot of individuals that are our
phenotypes in that group we think about
further directions there's a lot of
things that we can do to do development
of these scores and go forward and
hopefully make them have higher utility
one of them is that really we need
better development of annotation sources
specifically for protein protein
interaction data again getting back to
this idea of an omni genetic model of
disease there's part of this that it
suggests that there's a lot of features
that are perhaps not well captured by
our current methods that might be acting
at great distance on different genes
that are talking to a lot of different
partners and in that case a lot of these
protein protein interaction databases
might not be capturing that information
right now so there's there's been a lot
of advocacy for increased study of
transcriptomics and things like that in
order to improve these resources and
then in addition we want to think about
applying better community detection
algorithms to these models there's a
need here for something that's a little
bit more complex than levain algorithm
which really just looks at the graph and
how the graph itself is arranged to
start thinking about things like using
attribute weights on each one of the
nodes so that when it's deciding if
things go together that should things
that all have high signal go together
where should it draw those lines and
hotnet does this to an extent but is
more focused on much smaller sub
networks do the way that it's specified
so there's probably room here for more
developments of detection out there for
community detection algorithms and then
again when we're thinking about studies
into ROP and preterm birth it's likely
that we're going to need relatively
large cohort sizes in order to be able
to pull these two effects apart it seems
that our PM preterm birth are
significantly interlinked with one
another and because of this it would
make sense for us to try and get a lot
of individuals to get the most power as
we can possibly get them in our studies
and then finally one of the things I
want to talk about is the idea of better
gene level scoring so we were looking in
a lot of the
just pulling one snip that was
representative of a full gene so you're
taking the low significance snip or the
highest effect size snip or something of
that method but there are a number of
more subtle methods or more complex
methods out there for doing this gene
scoring that take into account multiple
snips inside each one of these regions
or take it to account like broader
linkage disequilibrium structure and
using some of those in the future might
be a good way to get back some
information on these genetic signals and
finally we want to see this data are
replicated in other cohorts if possible
again we're looking at a very small
sample size and I want to call that out
and in order to be sure that these
effects that we're seeing are real we
would like to see this done again in
another group of patients that we can
see the same effects I'm so in
conclusion today we described a novel
method of incorporating protein-protein
interaction network context and two
apologetic risk score and we look at
ways of interpreting its its usage and
doing the interpretation of the
biological context we can see there we
look at a novel method for assessing
that Network context and constructing
appears to show that it's possible to
increase the amount of context that we
have there both by using hotnet 2 and by
using our modularity method and then
also we propose a novel method of
looking at the degree of
interconnectedness between two different
phenotypes by using these polygenic risk
scores and the way that we're able to do
prediction based on them as a surrogate
for how interlink these disorders could
be specifically looking at ROP and
preterm birth and so if that I'd like to
thank a bunch of people I'd like to
thank my committee for all of their work
with me on this project I think
everybody in the Chang lab for being
super helpful and getting me up and
running and teaching me how to be a
scientist and I'd like to thank a number
of demise fellows who've done a whole
lot to both commiserate and help me out
with my projects and then everybody else
that he might have been hugely helpful
along with my funding from the NLM the
NIH and then I'd like to thank Breanna
for hanging out with me and being with
me through this whole process and for my
family for their support
so with that he'll open for for
questions and
[Applause]
I'm great talk thank you a little bit
more and then remind me was that just
for one of the sub modules what yeah so
generally what you get back from hotnet
is it does a a permutation and it kind
of compares the clusters that it finds
just a random bunch from the graph and
as you get less and less signal in
hotnet it finds progressively larger in
groups of genes that are together that
fit that criteria so when you don't have
enough signal it tends to find like
large batches of genes that aren't
really representative of biological
context it just finds big things that
are as close as it could narrow down so
you end up with these crazy large sizes
of sub networks that have an enormous
amount of heat that's associated with
them but that just are kind of like
random spots around the graph so it's
very difficult to do an interpretation
of what you're actually seeing there
without drilling down because it's too
small of a group to do something like
gse a and but it's too large of a group
to go through and like individually look
at each one of the genes and see what's
contributing and again like it's
difficult to tell because since hotnet
is sort of bleeding signal around the
graph you're getting groups of genes
that may have moderate effect you're not
getting like one clear winner that's
like concluding most of the effect to
that specific sub graph I don't think
that it's a cycle because hotnet likes
an undirected graph so it's I think
mostly just due to the fact that when we
look at the DN BC data specifically like
it's such a small group that you're just
not getting a good separation between
your strong effects and your weak
effects which is something that you
generally see in these G Wasa's and
apologetic risk scoring studies so it
seems that there's a fair amount of mess
in there between the signal and noise
ratio and we can see that again when we
were looking at those random permutation
you include more and more snips you see
like there's kind of a downward trend
your predictive ability which is not
what we would expect and so some of that
might have to do with
just the level of noise that's there
you're including noisier snips at a
larger amount as you include more things
so I'm curious to know that about when
you were mapping your service to your
PPI Network
I was curious to know how you dealt with
how you dealt with including genes that
occurred in one LD region whether you
include them both whether you chose one
at random or tried to pick the one
closest to the index snip in that class
yeah in this case we were just taking
that as like a filter prior to LD
clumping so we were going forward we
would take every snip that fell within
that region and then that would go
through to the LD clumping and be
clumped after the fact and then that was
what was included in the score so
basically if you had multiple genes that
were in the same region those snips
would be included and then the clumping
would happen on those and one would be
carried forward there's been a lot of
discussion that's been happening
recently about different ways to do LD
clumping when you're doing a gene set
based analysis so like the group that
does precise I think the guys name is
trishing Juan has a method that he's
currently working on that involves doing
per gene set clumping so for every gene
set that goes through you do clumping on
that specific gene set as if it's its
own entity to make sure that you have
good coverage across all the genes and
there's been some proposal that we
should be doing like per gene clumping
when we do this to try and get the most
signal rich snip so that when you build
a score you can get some idea of what is
is contributing to your predictive
ability from that gene set specifically
so those are things that are kind of
being discussed right now but we didn't
have the resources to get into writing
like a total like C++ based thing in
order to do a custom clumping and LD
matching for stuff like this so what we
did is we primarily just looked at this
as a filter before we did the LD
clumping and then from that we chose our
most predictive threshold
haha yes oh oh you're talking in Paris
for the art piece for you when you all
sniffs - ROP what exactly it does it
entail exactly so we start out with a
full set of snips we look at the snips
that are involved in the RP Canada teens
course these are gene genes that are
associated with our LP and neighbors of
those genes based on our candidate gene
list that we had and we just subtract
those out from the full set so it's the
full set - oh those ones the selection
is gene base but we're identifying snips
within those genes and since we're
looking at the full that something that
I haven't looked at specifically to see
if there are regions between these genes
that are being left in that represent
those LD blocks so that is something
that I think makes sense - to address
thank you that you almost want to really
sort of take out LD clumps that's true
I'm just like no I think that's a really
good observation that makes a lot of
sense because it is true that we weren't
looking specifically at doing or
subtraction based on on LD regions think
about this from model complexity or bias
variance dilemma kind of setting I mean
what makes you how do you sort of
understand these kinds of things within
that complexity complex context um I can
tell you that one thing that I worry
about a lot is the size of our test set
for this because I think that when
you're dealing with millions of snips
and you're looking across these things
it's easy to think about overfitting
your data to your test set so one thing
that I I wish that we had was a larger
test set for this that we could better
address that idea of like the ROP snips
that we're seeing are they actually
predictive across a wide range of
individuals or just like this 250 cases
that were seeing specifically in our
test set here I think that it's I don't
know like partly we tried to address
that by looking at the random background
to see how these perform compared to
that random permutation you you're
exactly yeah no I mean do your exact is
sort of expressing my considering that
the thing is the the data set you have
such a size that it may be really
favoring a much smaller model yeah
that's also something to consider while
like writing is up for publication yeah
and I think these are really great
analysis to do but this is just one more
and there are some ways we can do
another sort of again doing more of this
essentially to see if that's really
happening
in terms of overfitting of the other
sort of larger gene models yeah I agree
and I think that again like you can see
that here and just like the degree of
spread that you're seeing so like as you
get to smaller proportions of snips that
are involved in the score you're getting
the most predictive scores randomly from
that set and so I don't know again if
that's just because you're randomly
hitting on things that are over
represented in our test set because it's
so small or what the the logic behind
that is I just had a question about like
you're you may have said it I might miss
it but your rationale for using pre term
for using ROP to predict preterm birth
I sort of like my inclination maybe or
my intuition i although i know i'm not
sure if i can express it perfectly yeah
first yeah it's a it's an issue of the
data set we just don't have ROP data
sets of significant size like we were
hoping so when we started looking at
this data set it was kind of advertised
as being enriched for ROP and so we
thought that we could do that and build
a score with ROP build a score with
preterm birth and then kind of see how
those some together or how those compare
to one another but the number of ROP
patients in the cohort was too small
once we actually got a look at the data
to be able to really do that so in order
to get the best ability to somehow
quantify the amount of overlap between
these two things what we need to do is
focus more on the preterm birth side and
then go from era PETA seeing if we can
predict in in in preterm birth whether
we can find the cases and the controls
and stuff so yeah that was the rationale
there is it's mostly dictated by the
data sets that were available to us so
if you now look at the data if we think
that your candidate genes were the
equivalent in the antigenic model of the
core genes yeah right so they're not
gonna
they predicted that it's not going to
explain everything
mm-hmm knowing what you know now we're
gonna do this again and thinking about
it from an auto genic perspective what
what do you think you would do to
enhance the model right cuz you've gone
at it as a straight PPI Network approach
which made sense yeah but if we actually
want to try and have an on genic kronole
yeah I mean part of this the interesting
thing I think would be the ability to
try and figure out if we can identify
core genes that are perhaps a
significant effect when we see them or
like which genes have the most partners
I'm assuming that you did let's say the
candidates are the core the real issue
is what we're missing right is the right
the other it's the non core yeah right
it's everything outside the core
pathways is actually where the old genic
yeah it's difficult I mean it's
difficult for me to consider exactly
what the best way to go for it is
because what we really need is we need
better resources for interactions
because it's difficult to see what's
talking to what and they're bent like
again Jonathan Pritchard and I think the
guy's name is Louie Frankie the
university are working together trying
to do larger T wah studies in order to
look at more expression data order to
get better pictures of like what is
being expressed and so maybe moving this
to a more expression based context and
trying to duplicate the same kind of
predictive scores and look at things
like that would be one way that you
could do this just because we need a
better picture of what's causing these
effects and then also like maybe in a
perfect world I'd love to have like a
huge group of people that have like just
a whole genome sequencing or something
like that so we can look at more rare
variants and see if there's something
that's not necessarily captured by these
chips that might be indicative of
smaller amounts of a predictive outcome
that we're missing here somehow it that
makes a that make sense
right so you mentioned the size of the
test set yeah well I mean basically I
think the biggest difference is that the
size of the discovery set just really
limits our ability to distinguish signal
from noise and so we probably have a lot
of real signal here that's being lost in
a lot of like spurious signal that we're
getting just because it's a small group
of individuals and it's you know maybe
we have an over representative group of
people here I mean in addition to the
size of the discovery set you have other
things that are related to like
stratification we're applying this
across from a discovery set to a test
set in our case specifically we're
looking at this DMV C data set which is
relatively I don't know it's it's it's
one set of background so we're looking
at like Danish individuals which is
relatively concise but in the giant data
set there's been a little bit of work
coming out saying that it's it's
difficult to map across from your
discovery cohort to your test data set
if they're from different even like
hospitals or different health systems or
something like that even if the
stratification is relatively similar so
giant I think we also have that issue of
looking at like the way that the giant
study and the hrs study are different as
well but I think to get back to the size
question yeah and the D NBC it just
really has a lot to do with like my my
faith and how much we can believe those
results
I guess just because you have that big
distinction between the signal and the
noise that you're able to capture there
I'm great work I am I have questioned a
couple questions ago there was the issue
that came up about specific game 2 which
was sort of the relationship between ROP
and prematurity and you know you know
the question that that you had grappled
with like you know a couple years ago
was this question of our people really
at risk for ROP per se or they actually
just is it just a sick quality of being
premature and you know stepping back one
step you know a few years ago you wrote
this big genetics sort of paper and one
of the lines basically in the paper said
that there are some babies who have low
demographic risk meaning they're pretty
big and low sort of clinical risk
meaning they're really not that sick low
environmental risk yet they still get
bad disease so it's really this issue of
you know prematurity versus ROP and just
based on what you've done if you had to
go back and look at that genetic paper
what's your take on like are there
independent sort of genetic risk factors
yeah he is distinct from you know
prematurity yeah it's difficult to say
because I mean I think as you'll
remember when we did that paper there
are a lot of studies that have been done
in very small sample sizes so a lot of
these candidate gene lists are coming
back from groups of 20 or 30 individuals
that had like one single snip that was
being investigated 15 or 20 years ago
when our ability to investigate a lot of
these genetic causes wasn't as complex
as it is now and again just because of
the recruitment issues you're not seeing
a lot of like genome-wide Association
studies for ROP you're not seeing these
more global perspectives and so it's
really driven by that candidate gene
study and back then I think one of our
big arguments in that paper it was
basically that we need to start thinking
about this more like we think about
other complex diseases and start looking
at trying to get wide recruitment and be
able to get the sample sizes to do some
of these bigger studies so that
hopefully we can get at a more global
picture of what's happening there
because really as it's been done so far
it does seem that a lot of genetic
investigation of our ope has been driven
by like investigator intuition and the
idea of things that are associated with
these disorders